[Music]
welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio addressing some of the
biggest stories currently going on in
the national football league and there's
a story that is emerging week by week
game by game throw by throw dak prescott
on pace for over 5 100 passing yards
entering the final games of his rookie
contract peter what kind of a deal is
dak prescott currently playing himself
into when we consider russell wilson
currently is the highest-paid
quarterback at 35 million per year
well mike every single quarterback
contract simply plays hopscotch you know
that and
add to that the salary cap very likely
is going to go up probably to 200
million or right around that for 2020.
i believe in the dak prescott story that
there's one part of this that he and his
agents should strongly consider and that
is
what if there is a gig as part of the
next tv slash media deal
there is a
huge
portion of money uh and a big increase
because of streaming rights
and if that happens dak prescott i'm
sure doesn't want to be left at the
altar with a contract that is in early
2020 dollars
that basically would be around 37
million a year
and and look dak prescott making 37
million a year he hit the lottery for
the end of time i'm sure he's utterly
thrilled with with whatever he'll get
but as a quarterback you don't want to
leave a lot on the table and if i'm his
representatives negotiating with the
cowboys that's one thing that i think
would be very hard to pin down and would
make this contract a very difficult
thing to do
i agree with you completely peter and
the other reality is his contract will
be driven by the franchise tag in large
respects and they likely are going to
have to use the exclusive franchise tag
which currently would be 33 million a
year for the first year goes up by 20
the second year 44 the third year the
non-exclusive tag which will be around
26 million that opens the door for
someone to swoop in and make dak
prescott and offer the cowboys can't or
won't match and the cowboys would get
two first-round pictures compensation i
don't think they want to take that risk
this is the same conundrum that the
ravens had in early 2013 where they
didn't want to go non-exclusive tag they
didn't want to pay the exclusive tag
they didn't want to start down that path
because the numbers get out of whack
quickly so they just made
joe flacco the highest paid quarterback
in the nfl at the time and that may be
what they have to do with that
acknowledgement you know what peter one
of these quarterbacks is going to get a
term in his contract that has his
compensation tied to a percentage of the
salary cap so when it does go up as
there are new tv deals and new revenue
streams and new opportunities for the
league and the cap goes up and up and up
the quarterback will continue to consume
a commensurate percentage of the total
available cap dollars
i'd absolutely look for that if i were
prescott and i'm sure that jerry jones
would view himself as a guardian at the
gate
in fighting that very hard but jerry
jones oftentimes has done things that is
that have angered his other owners when
he gave deion sanders 13 million dollars
uh you know a 13 million dollar bonus
whatever year it was 94 or 95 i mean
imagine giving a defensive player that
much money which is in in today's
dollars would be you know 80 million or
whatever
and i think jerry jones wouldn't be all
that fearful about it but i also think
jerry jones absolutely does not want to
set that precedent i don't think he'd be
he'd be
frightened to do it but i just think he
would view that as a bridge too far
yeah but you know at a certain level
there's a there's an appeal to the idea
that you know we're not going to worry
about certain numbers we're going to
worry about specific percentage and
we're comfortable giving you 15 for
example of whatever the cap is in any
given year
as a businessman i'd like to think he
sees the logic but you're right it's
going to be a precedent center and if
one does it others will do it as well
either way i expect dak prescott to be
with the cowboys we'll just see when
they get the deal done and for how much
he will be signed check us out all
season long for more pft ot videos on
yahoo sports
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports